Now Jimmy, you're the best.
You're the king of games on your show.
I feel like you set the bar
and so we wanted to try a game with you here.
We've never done it before.
It's a trivia with a twist.
It's called "Who Knew?! Don't Spew."
Yeah, I don't...
(audience applauds)
I don't like the title.
I don't like the title already, I'm already freaking out.
Well, I know your worst fears.
So Ross, explain the game.
Oh my god, Jimmy is so nervous.
Okay, I'm gonna ask general trivia questions.
You're each gonna answer
the same question using your whiteboards
and for every wrong answer,
you have to take a step closer to your worst nightmare.
It's not mayonnaise, right?
Well Jimmy, you know, whoever gets the prize right
is gonna win a prize for your side of the audience.
Jimmy, you're playing for the left side over here.
Yeah, that's right, come on guys, let's do it.
(audience cheers)
Let's win, let's win, let's win.
Drew, you're gonna be playing
for the right side of the audience over here.
(audience cheers)
And Jimmy.
I feel like it's rigged.
I feel like this is rigged.
Okay, then you're gonna take a step
for every wrong answer toward the box.
Whoever reaches the yellow circle first-
Oh my god.
Will have to eat whatever is under the box.
Now you mentioned something
that you don't like, what was it?
Please, it can't be mayonnaise, it can't.
Oh, it can't be mayonnaise.
I will throw up if it's mayonnaise.
What's your worst fear, Drew?
Goat's cheese.
Oh yeah, you know what?
I knew this about both of you.
Let's take a look what's under there.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
We have...
It's so disgusting.
So yeah.
(Jimmy retches)
Ah, get away from it!
Look at this knife.
It is no good, don't do it!
No, no?
Okay, all right.
You guys don't understand
how big Jimmy's fear is with the mayonnaise.
It's...
(Ross laughs)
Are you ready to play?
I can't even look at it.
But I will win for you guys, I will win.
Okay.
I'm gonna do my best for you guys.
(audience cheers)
Okay, here is the first question, this is easy.
Which President is on the $1 bill?
Write down your answer.
If you get it right, you stay put.
If you get it wrong,
you have to step towards your worst fear.
Drew, George Washington.
(bell dings)
Yes, you both got it right.
Jimmy got it right too.
(audience cheers)
Clear your boards.
This is such a curveball.
Okay, question number two.
What is the largest continent?
(audience chuckles)
Drew wrote her answer down, she wrote "Asia."
(bell dings)
Oh wait.
Jimmy, reveal yours.
Wakanda?
(buzzer buzzes)
(Drew and Ross laughing)
Sadly, Drew got it right.
Are you sure?
Jimmy, that's incorrect.
So you're gonna step to our pink dot.
(audience applauds)
Are you sure Wakanda's not bigger?
I'll check it but I think it is Asia.
All right, next question.
Name Kim Kardashian's four children in chronological order.
Drew's writing.
(audience laughs)
We'll wait.
All right, reveal your answer.
Drew, you wrote "North, Saint, question mark, Psalm."
(buzzer buzzes)
Not, I mean really close though, I have to say.
Jimmy, what did you write down?
I wrote "Stick, Jack, Carl and Toni."
(Drew laughs)
(buzzer buzzes)
Any of them right?
(audience applauds)
Well, you're both gonna walk forward one step.
Oh, Chicago, right.
Yes.
North, Saint, Chicago, Psalm.
Okay, next question.
What is the periodic symbol for potassium?
(audience members laughing)
Drew wrote down "Po."
(buzzer buzzes)
And Jimmy wrote down?
Pp?
(everyone laughs)
It is the letter K.
K!
K.
Yes, you're right, K.
We have scientists up here in the audience, letter K.
A lot of people knew that.
How about this?
This question's worth five points.
Is it?
Yes.
Well, you're both stepping forward.
That's all I know, okay?
Step forward.
This one's worth five points.
One, two, three.
Yeah, whoever gets this one wins.
All right, so here's the question.
Johnny Carson was the host
of "The Tonight Show" for 30 years.
What was his astrological sign?
(audience laughs)
Any other question.
Any other question I could get.
Johnny Carson, what car did he drive?
What is his astrological sign?
Oh my god, I don't even know if Johnny knew.
(audience laughs)
I didn't even know he had an astrological sign.
All right, reveal it.
Drew wrote "Scorpio."
Jimmy wrote "Virgo."
Why are you laughing?
Well, 'cause there were actually two answers.
I would to accept Libra or Scorpio 'cause he was on the cusp
but he was not a Virgo.
(buzzer buzzes)
(audience cheers)
Which means Drew stays.
But Jimmy,
you must step forward.
I'm honestly really freaking out right now.
This is like, honestly.
Hold on, we got you a little one right here.
(Drew giggles)
All right, hold on, hold on, let me just focus up.
I don't know if I wanna use a real spoon either way.
All right, just a pinky.
Okay, we'll take a pinky.
Will we accept a pinky, yes?
(audience cheers)
Ugh.
(Jimmy retches)
It actually is too much on my pinky.
I put too much of my pinky on there.
(audience applauds)
Oh Jimmy, oh Jimmy.
Okay.
Just get it off.
Can someone get it off?
Yes.
Can you get it off with this please?
Here, I'll just, here, you got it.
Anything to get this off my body.
Okay.
It is unbelievable.
Does my side get any prize at all?
(audience cheers)
Ew!
It is disgusting what that is.
Unfortunately Jimmy,
you did lose.
Yeah.
Which is a very rare thing but good news,
you're all going home with a $100 gift card to Bookshop.org.
Yeah, I love Bookshop.org!
He did it, he did it.
It's so good because
Bookshop.org supports local bookstores.
Bookshop.org supports local bookstores
and that is so important.
We love Bookshop.org.
I love book sellers
of all varieties and also you can get a copy
of course of the one and only "Nana Loves You More,"
Jimmy's new book in his franchise of children's books
and it's available now online and in stores.
Oh my gosh.
You were so brave.
I will say a true friend would eat the goat cheese.
Yeah.
To support
Jimmy.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, you're right, that's actually a great idea.
I guess it just occurred to me.
(audience cheers)
(Ross gasps)
Yeah, all right.
Ew, ew, ew!
Oh god.
I got it.
Oh.
(Drew retches, screams)
All right, that's it, guys.
(relaxed guitar music)